whereas it has pleased almighty God
to call to his Mercy our late Sovereign
Lady Queen Elizabeth II of blessed and
glorious memory
by whose decease the crown of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland is solely and rightfully come to
the Prince Charles Philip Arthur George
we therefore the Lord's spiritual and
temporal of this realm
and members of the House of Commons
together with other members of her late
Majesty's privy Council
and representatives of the Realms and
territories aldermen and citizens of
London and others
do now hereby with one voice and consent
of tongue and heart
publish and Proclaim that the Prince
Charles Philip Arthur George Is Now by
The Death of our late Sovereign of happy
memory become our only lawful and
rightful liege Lord
Charles III
by the grace of God of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland and of his other Realms and
territories
King head of the Commonwealth
defender of the faith
to whom we do acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection
beseeching God
by whom kings and queens do reign
to bless His Majesty with long and happy
years to Reign Over Us
God Save the King